today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
in the wake of donald trump's completely
depraved and deplorable maskless stunt
at the white house monday evening after
leaving the hospital with coronavirus
jack holmes wrote
a very good piece in esquire about
really what is the urgent decline of
america
and the pressing imperative to remove
donald trump
and he really hits many important points
that i want to talk about jack writes in
his piece quote
we have been heading down this road to
ruin for some time now but the end
stages are somehow uglier and more empty
than seemed possible and he adds that
quote if you were looking for a
portrait of an american empire in
decline
it arrived monday evening when donald j
trump
in the thick of about with covet 19
checked himself out of the hospital at
walter reed national military medical
center
and was flown back to the white house on
marine one
going on to say that quote he climbed
the curved staircase
reached the balcony and removed his mask
in what appeared to be a gesture of
defiance
of what the media the deep state
scientists reality itself
it was not immediately clear but that
trademark
pout was unmistakable this was
authoritarian chic
the president was looking at something
very strongly that's for sure
though it will not be an ounce of
humility or growth as a human being
after he was struck by the very disease
he's so long downplayed and ignored
at the cost of so many american lives
and this article which i would encourage
you to read
outlines the mockery that donald trump
has made of personal responsibility and
how actions have consequences
the excesses of empire the delusions of
grandeur
but i'd go even further donald trump has
completely
undermined the executive branch of the
united states
he's undermined the justice department
he's undermined science and education
and the people of america and common
sense
he's undermined and and really
eliminated
the status of the united states as a
worthy participant
in the experiment of humans on planet
earth that is the degree to which this
man has debased
homo sapiens on this planet
we are now a joke and we are pitied by
the world now it's not you know for a
while they were merely laughing
when i now hear from our friends in
other countries
they are scared for for us and for
themselves
and they pity us and we are the danger
corrupt leaders the world over
are enjoying the catastrophe that is the
world under trump
while our historical allies in western
democracies
are horrified and they're desperate for
a change for a return to normalcy
and part of the problem part of this
rapid decline
has to be accounted for in the more than
60 million who voted for trump in 2016
and the likely more than 60 million that
will vote for him
again this november so we often talk
about
trump the people under trump the people
who work for trump the kaylee mcinannies
and the sean spicers they deserve to
never work again
because of what they've participated in
but what about the 60 million
trumpists that are part of this
debasement what happened
to supposed christian values on the
republican side i guess it was just bs
they were blowing smoke
can't republicans see a man who was
lying to them
all the time for his own purposes as not
in line with what they claim to be about
do they see it and not care is there
that much cognitive dissonance taking
place
consider how absurd the hospital stunt
was
notice that trump came home from the
hospital
with the orange face after having the
white face for a few days
while at the hospital because he wasn't
getting the makeup contagious
with covid trump had his makeup done by
someone at the hospital
the micro is pathetic and the macro is
simply dystopian
how much more of this can we take
unfortunately the wright seems
more than willing to take much more of
it i spotted this comment on a
right-wing
enclave on the internet reacting to the
trump photo op propaganda video when he
came
back from the hospital they said quote
people on the left are going to lose
their minds this is going to be so fun
to watch
that is emblematic of what we are
fighting right now it's not about
conservative values if you actually look
you don't have to agree with them
but if you just find sort of like a
normal traditional conservative
they have essentially nothing in common
with donald trump
this isn't about economic policy this
isn't about social policy
it's about angering the left as they
said the left is going to lose their
minds
over trump flying back from walter reed
in a helicopter
they want to own the libs trigger the
left as they like to say
so democrats must win in a landslide
this november if we are to avoid
a chance of another four years of this
and
probably democrats need to win in a
landslide on
i hate to say this but to avoid the
violence i fear we will see
if it's close and trump says it was
rigged than i really won
we need a landslide to avoid the
violence as well
the window of opportunity is closing
here we are now
just uh what is it 27 days to go
as of today barely to 26 and a half days
the window is closing and we have a real
opportunity here
and fortunately joe biden is actually
starting to help his own cause
and i want to talk about that next
yesterday as donald trump was sending
tweet after deranged tweet from the
white house
possibly hopped up on the mania caused
by this steroid
dexamethasone that he's on to treat
coronavirus
joe biden went to gettysburg
pennsylvania and delivered
one of the best political speeches i've
seen in years at minimum now for years
most of the speeches have been for
by trump so that this bar was not
necessarily high
um it it's really hard to care about
political speeches
when you follow this stuff so closely
the way that i do
because rarely is any one speech
particularly good or notable but joe
biden's speech yesterday in gettysburg
was fantastic and most importantly
it was the right speech at the right
time so let's look at some clips here is
joe biden talking about the division
in the country take a look there's no
more fitting place
than here today in gettysburg
to talk about the cost of division
about how much it has cost america in
the past
about how much it is costing us now
and about why i believe in this moment
we must come together as a nation
i have to say this was a well-written
speech
but it also fits as such a perfect
contrast to trump's
antics trump's antics are making it so
easy
to write these and to simply be the
adult in the room
in comparison to the mess that's going
on it was a well-done speech regardless
but donald trump is really helping joe
biden here joe biden going on later
in this discussion to talk about the
racial unrest and again
this is so politically smart because
when you look at the top three issues
for voters coronavirus the economy
in light of coronavirus and racial
unrest in this country and and law
enforcement
trumps underwater on all three trump's
approval is in the toilet on all three
and for joe biden to focus on this is
very politically astute
in recent weeks and months the country
has been riled by
instances of excessive police force
heart-wrenching cases of racial
injustice and lives needlessly and
senselessly lost
by peaceful protesters giving voice to
the calls for justice
by examples of violence and looting and
burning that cannot be
tolerated i believe in law and order
i've never supported to funding the
police but i also believe
injustice is real that's a product of a
history
that goes back 400 years the moment when
black
men women and children first were
brought here in chains
i do not believe we have to choose
between law and order
and racial justice in america joe biden
is simply making a contrast
that actually makes itself joe biden
seems competent
joe biden seems stable he seems like a
steady hand
period that is the contrast and it was
so evident in this speech
joe biden going on to talk about masks
you know trump
rip it removing his mask when he arrived
back at the white house
uh in an evita-like moment that some are
calling covida
which is just great joe biden explaining
masks are not political they're
scientific
vaccines are not political they are
scientific and the big focus on trump's
coronavirus failures
makes perfect sense given the polling
it's estimated
that nearly another 210 000 americans
could lose their lives by the end of the
year
enough no more
let's just set partisanship aside let's
end the politics and follow the science
wearing a mask wearing a mask is not a
political statement
it's a scientific recommendation
social distancing isn't a political
statement
it's a scientific recommendation
testing tracing the development
and all the approval and distribution of
a vaccine isn't a political statement
it is a science-based decision
we can't undo what has been done we
can't go back we can do
so much better and you know although it
hasn't been in the news as much because
of captain covid catching the virus
we again had nearly 45 000 cases
yesterday
it's building again and it could be
getting much worse as we get
to election day over the next 27 days
joe biden
starting to wind down the speech with a
conciliatory message
that is very much welcome to millions of
americans or welcomed by
millions of americans as president
i will embrace hope not fear peace
not violence generosity not
greed and light not darkness
i'll be a president who appeals to the
best in us not the worst
i'll be a president who pushes toward
the future
not one who clings to the past i'm ready
to fight for you and for our nation
every day without exception without
reservation
and with a full and devoted heart
we cannot and will not allow extremists
and white
to overturn the america of lincoln and
harriet tubman
and frederick douglass and then biden
clarifying
and again this is not it was a very well
written speech
the concept of a conciliatory message
is not that notable but because the
contrast
is trump joe biden clarifying he will be
the president for everyone
is again a really great way to draw
contrast things used to work joe
but they can't work that way anymore
well i'm here to tell you they can and
they must
if we're going to get anything done
i'm running as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work with democrats and republicans
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me
as those who do that's the job of a
president
the duty to care for everyone
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
is not due to some mysterious force
beyond our control
it's a decision it's a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate we
can decide
to cooperate as well just pitch perfect
pitch perfect this is the message
america wants and needs to hear right
now
we have to go in a different direction
what we've been doing isn't working
it's a complete speech it had you know
going
it's like uh middle school english right
it had a beginning a middle and an end
it had a logical conclusion that
followed from the premises
it was a clear contrast with a sort of
historic element to it
uh biden expressing a commitment to
reuniting a nation that has been
so divided rightly so this is not one of
those divisions that is artificial
half the country seems unwilling or
unable to realize that we have a
president who has
brought the country to the brink quite
literally and
joe biden very much triggering donald
trump with this speech
shortly after biden was done in
pennsylvania remember
the speech was in gettysburg
pennsylvania donald trump tweeted
how does biden lead in pennsylvania
polls when he is against
fracking jobs second amendment and
religion
those are all lies fake polls trump says
i will win pennsylvania hopefully not
we're going to talk about arizona later
but in the latest polls out of
pennsylvania biden
leading by an average of 6.3
and by as much as 11 in the latest
monmouth poll
biden can win pennsylvania early voting
is happening now
in pennsylvania it started weeks ago and
runs through october 27th
we have the opportunity let's make it
happen
if you are voting already in
pennsylvania or wherever
let me know how it's going i'm on
twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember membership at joinpackman.com
the number one most reliable most
exciting
most beautiful way to support the david
pakman show grab a membership at
jointpakman.com we do have hatred mail
you
we can't possibly get this close to an
election and not have hatred mail
reminder about what hatred mail
is because coveted 19 is just
another liberal hoax promoted by the
fake news media
but if president trump gets it you
better not make fun of him because this
is serious patriot mail
written by patriots who hate david
pakman
because america and because
freedom okay there's actually
a really important topic that i want to
discuss which is brought up
in this edition of hatred mail take a
listen
this david loser is such a cry
baby go back to your safe space and
don't forget to give your support gerbil
a hug
god you leftists are such snowflakes
trump 2020 trump is better than obama
fdr any other president we had since
lincoln
stop hating how much will you cry
when trump is re-elected i wanna see it
you better stream it live
so this continued idea of how much will
i
cry it when trump wins more like if
trump wins listen
the polls aren't looking good for donald
trump if trump wins
it's good for me financially i've said
this before i'm not pushing for joe
biden
because it would be good for my business
it's obviously
better for my show to be in the
opposition
and the truth is living in massachusetts
i'm relatively
insulated from much of the day-to-day
damage that trump does
obviously you know when i go to another
country i'm embarrassed
to be coming from the united states when
trump is president that doesn't change
regardless of what state i live in but
this entire idea of
i will cry when trump wins i will be sad
for what it means for the country but
it's really not about me this is about
improving the united states for
everybody
and i i i mean it's like it's not this
is not about me but if i'm totally
upfront
we do better when there's a lunatic in
the opposition in the white house that's
the reality and
and that's okay we i want joe biden to
win for the good of the country
but if anybody's expecting me to cry on
election night
um you you i would not hold my breath i
would not hold my breath for that either
way
make sure to fight patriotism in your
community by using the coupon code
hatred 40 when you sign up
at joinpakman.com the coupon code saves
you
40 and you can use that code on
any membership at joinpacman.com it is
spelled
h-a-t-r-i-o-t 4-0
so we have a really dicey situation that
is sort of the coming together
of donald trump's voter suppression
tactics
and demeaning of vote by mail and
absentee ballots
donald trump's nomination of amy coney
barrett to the supreme court
which could directly impact what
ultimately happens
with many absentee ballots which could
ultimately impact the results of this
election particularly if it is close
we know that there are some democratic
wins for both
the presidency and the senate which
could actually
hinge on hinge on absentee ballots and
we already have
a snafu we could call it per the
intercept
more than one hundred thousand absentee
ballot requests
have already been invalidated in
multiple iowa counties
in late august judges ordered two iowa
counties to invalidate at least 64 000
ballot requests
siding with donald trump the trump
campaign
brought a legal challenge the republican
party brought this legal challenge
they've been filing these lawsuits all
over the country
we told you they were ready with an army
of lawyers they are already deploying
them about 50 000 voters in one county
14
000 voters in another county will be
informed
that their request for an absentee
ballot won't count and if you still want
to vote by mail
you have to send a new form so you have
here 64 000 people
plus 92 000 in a separate case
in johnson county which is where
university of iowa is
expecting a more abiding leaning
electorate in that county
this is like a total of about 150 000
ballots now that we are talking about
they sent requests for an absentee
ballot
those have now been invalidated thanks
to this lawsuit
and many of those people may not know it
they may be sitting there
waiting for their absentee ballot to
arrive which may never arrive
unless they submit a new request then
early last week a fourth judge sided
with the trump campaign and the
republican party
upholding a recent law making absentee
voting
harder in iowa republicans push the law
in iowa over the summer it slows down
the process
for getting through and sending out the
absentee ballots
it makes it more difficult to get people
their ballots on time
what are democratic party officials
doing they're scrambling they're you
know always half a step
to two steps behind they need to now try
to contact people
who believe they have an absentee ballot
coming to them but
actually don't and they need to figure
out how do we communicate with these
people
how do we get everybody to request a new
absentee ballot
very expensive not impossible but very
expensive so
is there any good news here okay if i
need to find some good news
the good news is in most electoral map
scenarios
iowa is not likely to be the deciding
state it's it's unlikely
that to biden getting to 270 electoral
votes
will hinge on the results in iowa
the bad news is they're going to pull
this and they're already pulling this in
many different states
so we have to understand the timelines
and we have to understand the deadlines
monday two days ago was the deadline to
register in many states
i i mean i'll give you the list even
though the deadline has passed
ariz arizona arkansas florida georgia
hawaii
indiana kentucky louisiana mississippi
ohio
south carolina tennessee and texas did
you register because if you didn't it's
too late
okay if you're unsure if you're
registered google check
voter registration your state and you
will figure out how to confirm
your status delaware is coming up on
october 10th you have until october 10th
to register in delaware
idaho is october 9th illinois was
yesterday
maryland is uh next monday i believe it
is missouri is today
you have until today to register in
missouri new mexico
is yesterday new york is friday these
dates are coming the election is
happening now there's no more time to
wait
vote.org has all of the information
about how to register
how to get an absentee ballot how when
and where to vote early
everything you need we had early voting
start
this week in california iowa maine
nebraska south carolina
if you're in those states you can start
to vote now
early voting in indiana and ohio started
yesterday
arizona starts today georgia starts
monday kentucky and texas
tuesday a bunch more next wednesday the
election
is now my friends and this is not the
time
to keep waiting for something it is time
to act right now
they are going to pull every dirty trick
that they can they have lawyers ready to
go
they will try to challenge absentee
ballots they will try to stop the
counting of absentee ballots a new poll
which i'll talk about tomorrow
has donald trump down hope you're
sitting
21 points it's just one poll
but the numbers are getting very ugly
for trump and the uglier they get
the more all caps tweets we can expect
to see from him on twitter
and the more they are going to try to
use lawyers and other
subterfuge to steal this election
there is no more need to wait to remove
the insanity
the election is now yes we need
automatic voter registration
this this entire paradigm of registering
to vote and deadlines
disaster okay we need to fix it we need
to fix so many problems
but we have four weeks minus a day
right 27 days to go we have to vote
right now we will keep
pushing this make sure for the latest
updates
on voting and how it's going that you're
following us on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as
well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
yesterday after donald trump abruptly
tweeted out
no second coronavirus stimulus after
conversations with mitch mcconnell and
other lawmakers the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
got on a phone call with house democrats
and they were talking about donald trump
tweeting out
we're not doing a second stimulus which
seems like it seems like
the last opportunity trump had to do
something to actually gain some votes in
this upcoming election and nancy pelosi
suggested or wondered whether donald
trump's use
of the steroid dexamethasone for
treatment of his coronavirus
might be impacting donald trump's
decision-making ability because
even for the standards that we have come
to expect
for donald trump his behavior is out of
control
and last night hit and indeed donald
trump
appeared to have had a steroid-induced
manic episode on twitter
if you imagine the scene at the white
house
which at this point i don't know if the
white house is more like a psych ward
or a biohazard unit at this point i
guess it's like a biohazard
psych ward donald trump would not stop
tweeting last night things that make
absolutely no sense and it is again
raising questions about whether donald
trump is experiencing
mania as a result of the drugs he is on
to treat coronavirus now as i told you
earlier this week
it's not just observers from the outside
that have these concerns
donald trump jr as gabriel sherman wrote
in vanity fair on monday
donald trump jr reportedly
is worried that donald trump is manic
and wants to stage an intervention and
as we've talked about before
corticosteroid-induced mania is not an
uncommon side effect
from the drugs that donald trump has
been taking donald trump already has a
tendency to have this sort of
up-down manic and then depressed periods
or or
episodes and last night was completely
crazy okay so look
look at what is going on and remember
this is not
some obscure political advisor or a
podcast host
this is the president of the united
states at 7
41 pm eastern last night donald trump
tweeted
i have fully authorized the total
declassification
of any and all documents pertaining to
the
single greatest political crime in
american history
the russia hoax likewise the hillary
clinton email scandal
no redactions so it's a crazy tweet it's
already wacky
but then 40 minutes later donald trump
tweets
about these same documents which he
supposedly just declassified
trump tweets quote all russia hoax
scandal information
was declassified by me long ago
what you you just said you're
declassifying it now
trump goes on to say unfortunately for
our country
people have acted very slowly especially
since it is perhaps
the biggest political crime in the
history of our country notice
in neither tweet does trump actually say
what crime was committed
that's a theme but long ago you
declassified it
40 minutes earlier he announced he was
declassifying these documents
and 40 minutes later he says i actually
declassified this stuff long ago
people are even on the right concerned
about the mental state of donald trump
and whether this is being impacted by
the steroids that he is on it continued
all night
it kept going this morning seemingly
nobody able to get donald trump under
control
the speculation is that this is literal
roid rage the president roid raging on
twitter for hours
trump projecting about joe biden saying
quote
i just hope the voter understands that
they are all
fake news trying hard to push a man that
should never be president of our country
it sounds like he's referring to himself
there in 2016
right-wing media eventually when the
republican primary
was over uh getting in line and pushing
for trump
who should never have been president of
the united states
trump again erratically after stopping
the second coronavirus stimulus just
hours
earlier out of the blue trump tweets
quote
if i am sent a standalone bill for
stimulus checks
twelve hundred dollars they will go out
to our great people
immediately i am ready to sign right now
are you listening nancy this was just
hours
after he stopped negotiations and said
we're not doing a second coronavirus
stimulus
again is this some kind of roid rage is
trump thinking clearly
did someone get to him and say which by
the way would have been good advice
mr president sir as he likes to say
um the stock market imploded when you
tweeted no second stimulus
it was sort of like the last opportunity
in these 27
28 as of yesterday days before the
election
to do something good for the american
people and maybe regain some votes
maybe trump realized what am i doing
i'll now tweet i would sign
stimulus checks making no sense trump
then inventing a new number system
tweeting eleven comma double zero so
that's not
uh i i don't know uh you know what kind
of format that is one
one comma zero zero north carolina
residents get incorrect voter
registration forms
2 000 la county voters received faulty
ballots
with no way to vote for president many
others
throughout usa here we go
this will be the most corrupt election
in american history then trump
again after saying remember no more
second stimulus
tweets to demand stimulus money
for airlines tweeting quote the house
and senate should immediately
approve 25 billion dollars
for airline payroll support and 135
billion dollars
for paycheck protection programs
for small business both of these will be
fully paid for
with unused funds from the cares act
have this money i will sign now
and then a tweet that is both completely
incoherent
but very disturbing donald trump saying
quote
i don't even know what this means so i
had to constantly
fight off all this scum achieve
more than any other president in first
term
and then they talk chaos they
created crimes against me and
this administration there are dozens
more but the point here is
trump is more out of control than usual
and just imagine the scene at the white
house
trump already difficult to control trump
now
is on steroids which can cause mania
euphoria and delusions of grandeur and
anyone who wants to go near trump has to
wear full ppe
based on a report that we've gotten why
because trump has coronavirus and he is
presumably still contagious
unless he actually has had it for way
longer than we've been told
in which case he might be past the
contagious phase the the only
alternative
to trump still being contagious is that
they really lied about when trump first
tested positive
it is a man crumbling before our very
eyes a new poll has him down 21.
so where are we right now we could be
if we get the job done we could be
getting to the end
of this global nightmare but it depends
on you going out to vote
it depends on me going out to vote
believe me i'm going to vote i would
crawl over broken glass to vote i would
crawl
over shards of i don't know send me for
creative people
please send me some more metaphors i can
use
akin to crawling over glass to vote i i
would like to be uh
loaded up with some good ones for the
for the last four weeks of this campaign
we can move on to the end of this
national nightmare we have the
opportunity there's 27 days to go
so um okay let this is now i i want to
be clear that this is not
my idea doctors are saying that based on
donald trump's behavior of the last 72
to 96 hours
he needs a psychiatric evaluation all
right and and so
we saw we're i mean you could go back
years
but for this episode we saw on sunday
donald trump
while contagious with coronavirus donald
trump
went on a corona ride around walter reed
hospital with secret service agents in a
hermetically sealed
secret service vehicle to wave to his
supporters
this started to raise some red flags
that you know if you've not been paying
attention the last four years
maybe trump is not well mentally maybe
trump is not well cognitively
then donald trump pulled a bizarre
stunt where he checked himself out of
walter reed medical center on monday
flew back to the white house walked up
the back steps or the front steps i
don't know which is the back or the
front of the white house
and defiantly removed his mask
in his orange glory and filmed a
completely propagandistic video the
likes of which we anticipate seeing out
of north korea
but not necessarily the united states
even donald trump jr
has now said according to gabriel
sherman in vanity fair
monday that he thinks trump is manic and
that an intervention is needed well
leanna wen who is a cnn medical analyst
a doctor a visiting professor at george
washington university
said based on donald trump's behavior a
psychiatric evaluation
would be in order if trump were her
patient and left the hospital while
still infected
to go for a car ride she would
demand a psychiatric evaluation tweeting
quote
if trump were my patient in unstable
condition
with contagious illness and he suddenly
left the hospital to go for a car
ride that endangers himself and others
i'd call security to restrain him
then perform a psychiatric evaluation to
examine his decision-making capacity
that's a doctor my friends this is not
normal behavior
the barrage of manic tweets monday
morning
tuesday night it all
basically seals the deal that donald
trump
maybe as desperately as he needs
coronavirus isolation
needs a psychiatric evaluation now of
course we have to ask
could this be related to the
dexamethasone the steroid on which
donald trump has been put
to treat coronavirus uh maybe yeah
i mean why would trump risk people's
lives just to wave to fans outside of
the hospital well maybe it is the
dexamethasone but maybe it's just trump
because he doesn't care
donald trump has weaponized narcissism
and has destroyed any semblance of
empathy
over the last four years trump even
tried tweeting
that had he not done his corona ride
around the hospital
the media would have said he's wrong not
to do it
see if you can follow this trump tweeted
tweeted quote
it is reported that the media is upset
because i got into a secure vehicle to
say thank you
to the many fans and supporters who were
standing outside of the hospital for
many hours
and even days to pay their respect to
their president
if i didn't do it media would say rude
ridiculous there is no one in the media
who would have said if trump safely
stayed in the hospital
trump's really bad because he's not
driving around right now with
coronavirus
it's ridiculous secret service agents
were disturbed by it
a veteran secret service agent expressed
dismay
at the corona ride around walter reed
and
um did say that when you were around
trump it's difficult for people to say
no that if you say
no uh you you you suffer
uh that that it leads to even worse
outcomes it is
actually scary where we are as a country
right now
because not only do we have a president
who's been incompetent all along
his decision-making capability to the
extent that it ever existed
is particularly gone and you know we can
speculate
is it the steroids is it the disastrous
polling
is it that the white house is so highly
infected with coronavirus
it could be all of these things it could
be a combination okay
it doesn't really matter how do you
think he ended up in the hospital with
coronavirus he tried to make a mockery
of facts and science
and this is where we are right now
whether he's fit to serve
as president should not even be a debate
at this point in time
and yet 60 million or more people are
still going to vote for him and he could
could could but hopefully won't he could
get
another four years it is an existential
threat
not only to the united states but to
humanity for this man to get another
four years
he is out of control it is completely
weaponized
you all know what to do i won't even say
it let's just go to the break
you are it's four letters i'll tell you
that i'll tell you and we're 27 days
okay but i'm not gonna actually say it
you know what to do
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is actually incredible this is
sort of like the height
of a complete disconnect from the real
world
facts rationality empiricism common
sense
sanity it's the opposite of everything
that is good
i'm going to play a video for you of
trump campaign press communications
director
aaron perrine going on fox news
towards the end of donald trump's
hospital stay for
coronavirus and she says hey
trump now is the better candidate than
biden
because trump has the firsthand
experience
of having the virus joe biden doesn't
have that
in other words you should vote for trump
because trump has the virus and
joe biden does not she's making the case
that you should not vote biden because
he lacks personal knowledge
of what it's like to have coronavirus
and i am we're going to play the clip
first this
actually is a much bigger issue of the
lack of
empathy that exists on the american
right i don't want to get ahead of
myself let's look at the clip first
so is that something we should expect
with the best case scenario the
president leaves the hospital today
gets back out on the campaign trail will
we see changed messaging
when it comes to the coronavirus and
will it move more to a forefront
of the president's messagings and key
issues
well first-hand experience is always
going to change how someone relates to
something that's been happening the
president
has coronavirus right now he is battling
it head-on as toughly as only president
trump
can and listen that of course that's
gonna change the way that he
the way that uh he he speaks of it
because it'll be a first-hand experience
but you know that experience that
experience of not only coronavirus but
being president of the united states
that's why you just see a different tone
overall from him but it's been loving
the first hand experience sorry i'm
really good at it it's been law
order and it's been the economy does
this become a key issue and he's talking
about coronavirus as well
he's talked about it all and listen he
has experience as commander-in-chief he
has experience as a businessman
he has experience now of fighting the
coronavirus as an individual
those first-hand experiences joe biden
he doesn't have those he doesn't that's
right guys
trump now has experience fighting
coronavirus
on a personal level joe biden does not
because joe biden's been responsible
and donald trump has not and it led to
donald trump very predictably catching
the virus so i guess
vote trump over biden because trump has
coronavirus what a loser joe biden is he
can't even catch kovid
during a global pandemic well tell this
to the families
of the 215 000 we we were just like 80
deaths
shy a few hours ago of what will very
soon be 216
000 deaths due to coronavirus
say it to them that trump is the better
choice because he caught the virus these
are people
who will say anything at all that in the
moment
they believe will help get trump
re-elected and
now i this the real thing i want to talk
about here is we we've talked about
you know are there trump voters who
might abandon trump
because getting coronavirus makes him
look weak
as silly as that is aaron perrine is
making the opposite argument here which
is vote trump
because he has coronavirus and you know
the what's the logical conclusion to
this
show your solidarity with trump by going
out and getting coronavirus
yourself i mean it's it's the epitome of
irrational thinking
and they're almost making having the
virus some kind of
badge of honor in a sick way but
the really important thing i want to
focus in on is you know we've talked
before
about the homophobic republican
politician
who only when their kid or their niece
or whatever
comes out do they say i've i realize
i've been hurting people
i never knew what it would be like to
have someone in my family it's this
complete
inability to empathize with a situation
that is not actually their own
that's sort of the basis of this
argument right
if you believe that the only way to
really
understand the seriousness seriousness
of the virus
and the urgency of dealing with it
responsibly is to get coronavirus
then maybe you would vote for donald
trump but this is exactly the problem of
thinking we you know we hear from the
right all the time these examples
of how they can not empathize unless
they
specifically they personally are
affected by something
i'm not worried about that because i
understand that joe biden
much like many people even without
having the virus
themselves can understand the urgency of
dealing with with it can understand
how highly contagious it is can
understand the health implications the
economic implications
and on and on and on and then just like
to take this for a second and imagine
that it's a serious comment obviously
it's lunacy to say vote trump because he
caught the virus and biden didn't that's
crazy it's crazy to say that it is the
last gasp of desperation
hopefully it won't work but let's take
it seriously for a moment and imagine
for a second
that we want to evaluate this as a
serious thing to say
trump got the virus received a
helicopter ride
to top-notch health care from a team of
10
doctors and who knows how many nurses
and support staff
in a six-room medical suite or however
many rooms it is at walter reed medical
center
trump still doesn't have experience
receiving
the inadequate unaffordable health care
while either having lost your job or
having to figure out how can i survive
because now i can't work because i have
the virus
that has affected so many americans even
the argument
that now that trump had the virus he
better understands the experience of
americans
that's also wrong trump still despite
having coronavirus
does not understand the typical
experience for an american who either
has
or is related to someone who has had
serious coronavirus and again
why do they need to experience it
personally to finally have an awakening
and understand it it's like the anti-gay
republican
who understands their own homophobia
once their kid
comes out as gay or their niece comes
out as a lesbian or whatever the case
may be
these people are disgusting and we
absolutely must remove them
so tomorrow on the show i am going to
talk about a new
poll this is not some wacky poll it is a
serious poll from a good pollster
that has joe biden 21 points ahead of
donald trump nationally
and i'm going to tell you we should
pretend as though that poll doesn't
exist then we have to go and vote but
that's tomorrow
today i want to talk about arizona there
is a
stunning new poll this is out of arizona
where joe biden
is reportedly ahead of donald trump by
eight
points which is biden's largest lead in
arizona in recent memory now of course
this is just one poll in an average of
recent polls
donald trump is now trailing joe biden
by 3.4 points on
average in arizona still nothing huge
nothing certain but that eight point
lead in the latest poll the only poll
that we had recently
is very very important and in similar
news from arizona
sort of in the same poll democratic
challenger mark kelly
is leading incumbent republican senator
martha mcsally by 11 points
that pulls mark kelly's lead to an
average of 6.6
there was a debate i believe it was last
night between mark kelly and martha
mcsally
cringeworthy performance by martha
mcsally she was actually asked multiple
times
because she's kind of been a trumpy
right she was asked are you proud of
what donald trump has done she refused
to answer
it was absolutely cringe-worthy she
embarrassed herself
and the reason that these polls are so
compelling and noteworthy
is that if you look at the history of
arizona in presidential elections
you see that the last time a democratic
presidential candidate won
arizona was 1996 that's 24 years ago
when bill clinton defeated bob dole
and won the presidency and before 1996
the last time a democrat won arizona
was 1948 in the last
72 years a democrat has only won
arizona twice if these numbers were to
hold in arizona and joe biden wins by
three four five six seven it would be a
signal
that it is going to be a very bad night
for donald trump now on the other hand
if it goes differently
it could be a perfectly fine night for
donald trump important to know for our
friends in arizona
the last day to register to vote in
arizona was
monday so that date has passed other
important dates
absentee ballots are being mailed out
today october 7.
early in-person voting will begin very
very soon
dates and hours may bear vary based on
where you live
contact your county for details
about in-person early voting locations
and hours operate of operation the last
day to request
a ballot for absentee assuming you're
already registered will be october 23rd
weekend voting will happen on october
24th
and very very important for our arizona
friends if you plan to
mail your ballot you have to mail it by
october 27th
must be postmarked by october 27. this
is very important
in some states as long as you mail the
ballot by election day
it will count that is not the case in
the very
important state of arizona you must mail
the ballot
by october 27 and then of course
november 3rd
in person voting election day every
single state
we will be there so what do we take away
from these new polls in arizona that
show joe biden in an increasingly strong
position
they show mark kelly in an increasingly
strong position against martha mcsally
the polling tells us
only that we have an opportunity
to make some real change here the
polling tells us that
we must vote the polling tells us that
our vote can actually make a change
happen in our country
that if you imagine a big cruise ship
very very difficult to redirect takes a
while right
big heavy massive object
we're trying to reorient it a few
degrees
just a few degrees if you leave the port
of boston
heading towards europe a few degrees of
difference here
is the difference between ending up in
the uk
versus ending up in morocco all right
that's the metaphor that's the analogy
please and thank you
let's all vote let's all make this
happen we have a voicemail number that
is 2192 david p
i got a voicemail from our friend dr
eric
dr eric has two theories
about donald trump's coronavirus both
logical let's take a listen
david how are you doing man dr eric
holland from new jersey
called a couple other times i've treated
a lot of coping
in the hospital um i wonder what you
think about the idea that
trump actually tested positive a while
back
and they were hedging and planning on
never even disclosing it to the public
and hoping they would luck out and never
have to and
it was only after he started getting
sick that they said there's no way we
can do this and they conjured up he just
tested positive and oh now we're
bringing it into the hospital uh
preventatively proactively
yeah i think that that we're gonna get
to the part two of dr eric's voicemail
that explains a lot of things it
explains why doctors won't answer
when trump had his last negative test
because it probably wasn't
the day you know tuesday the day of the
debate last week
trump showed up too late to be tested
and they went on the honor system the
idea being oh we tested him when he got
on air force one and he tested negative
in all likelihood he wasn't tested it's
even possible that he had already tested
positive by that time that would explain
it when we wonder
why was trump given treatments that are
usually only given further into the
course of the disease like dexamethasone
when donald trump got it on like day two
of his treatment well
maybe it wasn't really day two maybe
that was actually day six
or day seven so what dr eric suggests
explains a lot of the irregularities
let's continue
i don't know that to me i wouldn't put
it past him the other thing is he does
not
have a cake of coronarius or some
non-descript coronavirus illness he has
coped
ammonia dn normal cat scan they would
have said so so
he's got pulmonary bilateral ground
glass opacities
and he's got high inflammatory markers
cop otherwise they would have said they
were normal
he had a fever low oxygen that's copic
pneumonia and they they're really not
disclosing it that way
yeah so dr eric i i believe is
completely right here during the press
briefings with dr
sean connolly conley dr uh uh the doctor
for donald trump uh
he very vaguely said that trump's scans
and and x-rays you know whatever imaging
they did
that it all uh was in line with trump's
health status and the progression of his
disease and then when he was pressed to
say well
does it show pneumonia does it show
irregularities the doctor didn't say
and so of course dr eric is right if
they were able to honestly come out and
say
every scan was the scan of a completely
healthy person
they would have done it because they're
desperate to make trump look super super
healthy i think that dr
eric is completely right here it's
speculative but you heard it from a
doctor there and it coincides
if you have an understanding of
propaganda you would likely come to
those conclusions
dr eric has the benefit not only of
being a listener
to this program so that he understands
the propaganda component
as a doctor he also understands the
medical component and the implications
of the symptoms and the medications and
the timeline and progression of the
disease
well said dr eric thank you for the
insights
tonight is the vice presidential debate
between kamala harris and mike pence
there was question as to whether it
would happen there was question as to
whether there would be plexiglass
separating the candidates the harris
team said let's have plexiglas this is a
highly infected white house mike pence
was exposed at the amy coney barrett
super spreader event
and the pence team refused and said we
don't want plexiglas
if kamala wants to bring her own she can
bring her own well as of this morning
everybody has agreed to plexiglas it's
very very clear
that what happened over the weekend in
the debate between lindsey graham
and jamie harrison where jamie harrison
brought his own plexiglas
and it just looked bad it made it look
like lindsey graham doesn't care and
isn't taking coronavirus seriously
clearly the pence people realized why
are we fighting this we're going to do
more harm if we continue fighting the
plexiglas so we will have a with
plexiglas debate tonight
the debate starts at 9 00 pm eastern but
i have a suggestion
join me for the pre-debate show with
your comments and questions and a lot of
different things i will also be debuting
a new
um a new song that i think people will
very much enjoy
i will be live starting at 8 30 eastern
maybe even 8
20 eastern um on youtube
and twitch youtube and twitch join me
there for the debate tonight
before that we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today the united states
supreme court is again
reviving criticism of gay marriage we
will talk about the latest bombshell
report about
child separations at the border and we
will talk about how the
senate majority being in the hands of
democrats or republicans
after all is said and done on november
3rd
the senate majority may now hinge on
a sexting scandal in north carolina
not everybody agrees it's a scandal but
some people say that it is a scandal
we will discuss all of those stories and
much more
on today's bonus show get access
by becoming a member at joinpacman.com
otherwise i will see you tonight for the
vp debate
live stream don't miss it
so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save twenty five percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video